All right,
we are back live.
We are good.
All
right, here's the plan. Crush the Crush
the new algorithm.
So,
something's weird happening with the the
advantage.
We're getting high uh high errors
on levels that should be fully solved.
Offender level three.
Solve rate 997.
Segment priority of 45.
Segment length of 60.
Yeah.
So wait, it predicts an advantage of 12.
Hey Tim,
still grinding so plus state set things.
Wait, what does that mean?
Am I getting this wrong?
near terminal states with huge
residuals.
that just makes us rely on our shorter
bootstraps.
I honestly have no idea. I honestly have
absolutely no idea what this is. It's
just like very weird value function
spikes. Huh.
Has nothing to do with any of the
fancier things I was thinking about.
It's just very weird value function
spikes.
Well, I guess that's at least like um
that's something we can figure out most
likely.
Okay. I mean, this will get us some
diagnostics pretty much. I want to know
every single time um
every time we get a segment that should
not have high advantage that does have
high advantage, I want to know what the
heck is going on. Is the value function
wrong or what?
the logs a whole bunch of crap, but
whatever.
I'm hoping this is just something dumb.
It could be the dumb advantage scaling
change that I made.
Actually, that seems like very likely
now that I think about it. That was
probably just really stupid on my part.
We'll see.
Yeah. Okay. I think that that was
sketchy of me, wasn't it?
I'll try that next.
I mean, idiot, you know, that I made
like that big of a change without fully
testing.
If that's it, then I'll say like, "Okay,
my bad. I wasted a day because idiocy.
It happens.
At least I remembered that I made the
change.
We'll check that and then I and then
we'll check the advantage norm thing.
Yeah, the more I think about it, the
more likely it is that that's it. That
totally messes up the um
that totally would mess up the targets,
wouldn't it?
Okay, we actually have lots of nice PRs
in here.
Very good.
As soon as I finish the algo stuff,
we'll have fun things to merge.
Two minutes left on this.
I think we'll have a few more runs, but
hopefully if I'm correct,
we'll just get like, yeah, the value
function is somehow nonsense. And then
we'll fix the advantage and then so
hopefully it should not be nonsense
anymore.
Oh, of course. Now we're going to get
the 14 solve.
immediate TD value mess at terminal
transition.
An immediate TD value miss at the
terminal transition
G propagation from rewards.
I swear if it's the stupid advantage
norm thing I did,
I'll feel very dumb, but I'll be happy
because it'll be solved.
We will see.
To have the value function screw up on
terminals would be weird. No.
Subtle discounted timing issue
the value. So, one step before terminal
got scaled reward 6.69.
Yeah, that's definitely the scaling
screw up. All right,
reward.
No, we don't do that.
We do um we do everything except like
big LLM RL
because the thing is those
like all the really big models because
of the way their action space is set up,
they just do really really stupid
reinforcement learning. Um and then they
just kind of have to burn money to get
around it.
Like they have a much weaker algorithm
than we have fundamentally.
Subtle discounted time is not a subtle
discounted timing issue.
One step before terminal
the value predicted no reward
then got a scaled reward.
It's a rare near timeout solve.
Okay. I see it's a tail event. Cool.
Not an immediate terminal TD error.
reward. Three steps later.
When I say the action space is weird
have to interact. So you can either look
at the action space as an entire
response in which the action space is
basically infinite or you can look at
the action space is each token in which
case you just have like a stupidly long
horizon problem.
um the former is probably closer to
correct
and that prevents you from being able to
train any sort of reasonable value
function
which means that all the things that
make RL actually work do not apply. So
you're stuck with very stupid
algorithms.
Like if you go try to take GRPO and make
it work on um on Puffer, you'll find
it's a really stupid algorithm.
So this was me like trying to do
something and not sufficiently testing
it.
Running scale on reward is very dumb. I
don't I've always known that. I don't
know why the [ __ ] I decided that I would
change that now without proper testing.
It's doing stupid [ __ ] but whatever.
It's fine.
action is an entire mini token response.
Yeah, you completely screw it up
because it's like the problem is the
action is the whole response.
It's not like which token was the good
token.
I don't know. Maybe there's some way
that they eventually figure something
else out, but for as long as they have
it that way, it's just screwed.
like they might figure out some crazy
latent representation way that lets you
basically push the entire vector in one
direction or another. I don't know.
There's like stuff you might be able to
figure out.
All right. I don't believe we're stuck
on two for.
It might have to like five or 6x
learning rate maybe.
Damn it. Stupid. Stop posting archive
link
there.
Hang on. Is Mike back? Yeah, Mike's back
working. Stupid camera.
So annoying.
Our camera will come back on in a
second.
if hyper all just shifted is the
problem.
Camera's frozen. Hang on. Yeah, it takes
a second
once it fails like that. There we go.
There.
I actually don't even know if this makes
sense. I think you still have massively
shifted hypers
because um
Oh man, that was such a stupid change.
Why did I do that?
Why would I ever do that? Why would I
ever like shift the rewards dynamically?
It's so bad.
And now I'm paying for it because now I
have stupid thing that's locked into
this very bad decision.
H.
Cool.
this at least will give us some logs.
Maybe
we'll see how well this does.
Any GitHub repo?
Uh, Puffer AI. Yeah, it's all open
source.
My repo is the Puffer AI repo.
This is my project.
Do you run with
Yeah. Star the puffer? It helps. Do you
run with mining active?
Yes.
Are you handling them when saving and
restoring states? Is it important? Uh
yes. So that is a limitation. you can't
really restore
RNN states reasonably.
Um, and even if you could, it does drift
to be off policy quite quickly. So, that
is one of the areas I've wanted to test
stuff. Like, is it better to just have
the network learn that every so often
its memory gets zeroed or to have to be
training with stale memory weights? I'm
not entirely sure.
I'm really not entirely sure yet.
But for now, I tested it. It doesn't
seem like that alone was the uh the
culprit.
I think that like we have pretty good
diagnostics at this point that we can
solve the whole task. Everything works
if you just get the right data into the
state buffer. So, we pretty much have a
very small error surface at this point
where it's just the data needs to get
into the state buffer.
What's wrong? Why aren't we getting uh
new samples?
Entropy. No, we have good entropy.
Oh, okay. There's 12. Doesn't latch
well, but it is there.
Just took forever.
What theme do you use for Envam? It's my
own. Uh if you go on the Puffer AI
GitHub, the Puffer Tank Docker also has
the uh the config file. It's very bare
bones, but it does have the color scheme
on it.
Okay, let's see what this gives us.
At the very least, this is on par with
the previous method.
Um, this I'm much more comfortable with
it being done this way
as well.
We still haven't gotten a 14 solve, have
we?
Oh, there it is. Okay, so we get 14. 14
with no domain knowledge.
So, we're back up to where we should be
and with good diagnostics and very close
to where I think the algorithm will
land. And now we need to just analyze
errors and fix. to analyze errors and
fix.
your advantage.
Okay,
that's better.
This is better. At least we no longer
have absolutely terrible numerical crap,
which is nice.
Little annoying to have to do this debug
loop, but hopefully we can get some
segments like this.
I mean, it is still weird.
It's definitely weird either way.
We are working on Puffer 5 algorithm
mostly debugging um just debugging some
weirdly scaled advantages.
That's on puffer ti. Yeah, it's a pain.
This is like very stupid codeex
debugging of crap. Um, it's a long
story, but we have this new algorithm
that's based on setable simulator state.
And uh I essentially we have a very hard
problem.
that the baseline doesn't solve. And we
added a whole bunch of domain knowledge
until we could solve it with a tiny
policy. And then we stripped away all
the domain knowledge and fixed stuff
until we could still solve the problem
like 90% of the way with no domain
knowledge. And now we're basically
trying to crack the last couple of
things that are tough to do without
domain knowledge in a general way.
And um it's pretty much just coming down
to
uh very weird advantage estimates in
some rare states and figuring out why
that happens.
Um, I it I didn't switch because of
model quality. I just got sick of giving
anthropic money. That's literally it.
It's not that deep.
Nah, BF-16's super stable.
We've never had any issues with our
BF16.
There's some rescaling stuff we had to
do.
It's a combination of rescaling and um
like just very weird tail events.
Like we're chipping away at the problem
quite consistently here. It could be
it's pretty much any day now.
right.
Have to run this stupid thing again.
Speed optimizations.
Well, I mean this is um this algorithm
if this works the way it should will be
a massive massive massive improvement to
puffer.
Um in fact the full thing could be
bigger than puffer 3 to puffer 4
at least on the pure algo side. We will
see.
It's going to be more problem specific
for sure. Like puffer 4 is just
generally better on everything, whereas
I believe this should be like just way
better on specific problem types.
There's no way.
No, it's actually quite feasible.
Like the thing is giving access to
setible state is like that is the single
largest boost in information you could
possibly give the algorithm
like reasonably.
So we are actually expecting like
they're going to just be a there's going
to be a massive massive difference in
capabilities purely based on algo stuff
um within the next version or two.
3 to four was huge. Yeah. And it's not
going to be anywhere near the amount of
engineering, right? But from the algo
improvements like we will be solving
qualitatively new problems.
problem type. Um, very hard exploration
problems.
All right, just passing by. Sure thing.
Thanks for dropping through.
This should be the diagnostic we need
here. I mean, hopefully we get some
advantages that actually make sense.
If it's a straight value error, I'm a
little bit more confused on what we do
about that.
Nice seeing if we're still working on
cool stuff. Oh yeah, progress gets made.
quite consistent these days.
One reward is all you need.
There's the title.
Okay,
there we go.
Oh, come on. Really?
There anything useful in here?
ing in grew in general
never zeroed at mid rollout terminals.
There's no terminal masking.
Um yeah, it's for simplicity. We just
didn't bother with that. Like I think in
general we probably
we probably need to do some more
ablations around the mining grew states
in the way we're doing that. Um, I will
say it's not just trivially it's not as
obviously bad as you would think because
the problem with RNN's in general,
right, is you're recording uh trajectory
segments
and if you're going to use the original
state at training time, like it gets
stale very quickly, right? because once
you do a single update, that's no longer
the starting state that you would
actually have. So,
you know, having it learned that like it
generally keeps the state, but then
occasionally it gets randomly zeroed is
kind of okay sometimes.
Um, I remember this being a thing that
we spent a little bit of a time ablading
in Puffer 3 and it actually like it
wasn't just like, oh yeah, this is
obviously wrong. We should change it.
It is something that I want to mess with
though. Um,
I will say not zeroing it on warm-up.
There is a bug where we don't zero it on
on warm-up, but that's a much smaller
thing.
We can throw some ablations in on that
once I finish this algorithm. I suppose
this algorithm is also going to be
sensitive to um that type of a thing.
Okay,
this will run. Um, this will take about
six minutes. I'm going to use the
restroom real quick, grab myself a
drink, take a little walk around, and I
will be back in like 6 minutes uh to
analyze this and hopefully we have some
insights. For anybody that's new around
here, Star Puffer on GitHub. It helps us
out a lot. I'll be right back.
Perfect. We got a nice latch fail on 11
to look at.
Takes forever. It really like um takes
me out of the loop here.
Good thing is our next our next set of
algorithm ablations are going to be way
easier than this. This is the last
annoying problem we have to solve for a
while, I'm pretty sure.
Which is nice. What's it 125? I think we
can probably if we just get this done
today,
I'll be very very happy.
I'll be very happy to have this done
today.
This is literally just it for getting
its own [ __ ] format.
But whatever.
The offending solve level segment.
There are only three cases
where the captured frontier solve rate
is low.
Okay.
Latest run. A final score. Yes.
Long latches on 11 and 13.
93 comparison events.
The three were frontier solve weight was
generally genuinely low.
Okay. four, six, and 13.
Frontier solve rate was 13. Offender was
99. I like five. Five looks good as
well.
In all three, the top 16 picks the
solved level offender.
Critic is giving huge value errors on
already solved levels.
Near-terminal reward is only about 22
reducing advantage
about equal to.82.
So the current failure mode is not the
frontier solve lack advantage.
They have strong positive advantage
ramps.
Solve levels still produce large advant
absolute residuals.
No. Okay, Max is bad.
Okay,
some of Max.
No, that doesn't see him.
Okay. So I mean it looks like there are
genuine just value function errors. It's
just tail events.
So you're competing with tail events is
all which is reasonable. You're
competing with tail events. It's
reasonable. It's a limitation of
advantage.
Okay.
With stronger separation.
Interesting.
We tried that before.
I'm kind of surprised by this. We'll see
if this is a real thing, but I want to
get my diagnostic data at the same time.
Which one is this? Oh, this isn't Oh,
yeah. Okay. This one. Sure.
Yeah.
There's some logs. Yeah.
Okay. Gross macros.
Why are you using Windows? Because this
is an old desktop and I don't feel like
reinstalling it. I'm not actually deving
on Windows. This is sshed into a Linux
box with a 5090. And for bigger
experiments, we have boxes with like a
bunch of cards. So there's no actual dev
happening on Windows.
blah blah blah blah blah. Okay, cool.
Um, so we're testing two things here.
We're testing a
different
advantage calc for the purposes of
adding segments to the state buffer that
at least from previous log should fix
some of the issue.
And then we're also going to get stats
on how long uh different types of
segments are sticking around.
And the hypothesis is that segments that
we're storing incorrectly like we're
that we're storing that just have big
val uh big error but where the policy is
actually good.
We should be able to get those out of
the buffer very quickly
because they just have to update their
value functions. And it's much easier to
learn the value function that's just
supervised um than it is to learn the
policy.
And we'll see from here.
We will see from here.
Higher ejection sample counts or stay
alive long. Yeah. Okay. So, if I haven't
screwed anything up, this should
basically be the remaining stats we
need.
Um, we will see whether this does better
off the get-go.
And then, uh, we will also see remaining
problems.
We still have to handle possibly
prioritization.
For sampling, we have to change a few
things with how we're sampling,
but we're entering the home stretch.
That's instant like level six. That's
nice.
We're going to have to ablate this
stupid metric, aren't we?
Instant level. Well, almost instant
level eight.
Boom.
All right. So, we'll see from here. But
that looks pretty nice.
That does look pretty nice.
I guess we'll get uh that's good in some
sense that we'll at least get some log
data on it.
And actually this will give us
would give us reason to use the bigger
buffers, right?
Oh, come on. Are we going to get in
instability?
No, I guess not. I guess we just crashed
for a second.
H.
We have the 12 gate open. Yeah, 13.
Okay,
we can We're getting 13 signal
Good pace.
Only one kind of bad latch level as
well.
I'm going to make an instant commit. If
this is 15.
Uh, we did get a 14 sample.
So, possibly we latch here.
Taking a while to latch. 130 mil
40.
Okay, it looks like we still have
latching problems on late levels.
Oh, okay. Not a great latch, but
could be worse. 260 mil
and then L15.
Got two minutes left to solve this one.
We'll see if we get any reward.
It's difficult to even get one lucky
solve on level 15.
I suppose this is one of the reasons why
you would want to be able to
you want to be able to explore from
resumed states. That's something to play
with.
Oh, okay. We got a level 15.
Uh, we only have 1 minute to latch it.
Let's see if that's enough.
We are getting a little instability.
Just a little bit.
must not get in the buffer.
That's a bad latch. Even if it does
solve, it's probably very close either
way.
But yeah, it's unfortunate.
We just just barely miss um
solving 15.
That's still worth committing, I'd say.
You'll see the crazy line counts being
added here.
That's all uh logging
that's getting deleted. So, I'm not too
worried
cuz like I know all this code is not
actually getting kept.
We're going to end up needing like 500
total lines for this update. It's mostly
just the algorithm.
Oops.
Try this.
Retrain this
and they research.
this is surprisingly decent at least to
start.
Possibly messes up now or later, but
it's not terrible. 140
level 10.
We fail latch level 11. Really?
Oh, there it goes.
This will give us slightly better
diagnostics at least on how um we're
managing the state buffer. So, that's
useful.
Where are we at?
Uh we are currently fine-tuning like the
way that we accept stuff into the state
buffer and then the way we sample from
the state buffer that needs to be
ablated.
Okay, let's think about something while
this runs.
State sets
from the
existing levels.
I actually can't think of a simple way
to do this off the top of my head.
I think that will help. If we can get it
to work from this state though, it will
definitely work from that one. I didn't
make this data set not explode memory.
It just doesn't take very much memory.
Man,
what's this? We're using 5 gigs of
memory total right now. Oh, wait. No,
that's VRAM. Hang on. 2.9 gigs of RAM
cuz the states are CPU.
Like correctly implemented state sets
just don't take a lot of memory.
What are we on? 14.
The 13 level solved. Maybe 14.
I'm not great latching. Oh, it was about
to latch. Level 14.
multiple hypers in the same run.
Um, no. Like kind of fundamentally not.
You can do like reward conditioning. So
you can train like a multitask model
in the same run.
But there's some hypers that like just
very much change.
They kind of change a
We'll solve rate segments once they
Enter.
that happened where maybe one level is
solved with one hyper.
No, you can just you can solve you can
solve um you can solve all the levels
just fine.
We don't need to be running like per
level sweeps.
Um
it's currently it is uh some it's mean
of positive advantages
at the moment.
Okay, we have to think about the explore
from state thing, right?
Oh, hang on. I think the terminals thing
is killing us, isn't it?
Yeah. Yeah, the terminals thing is
killing us.
I was just curious what happens with one
segment here.
See, it's probably way noisier.
want to learn RL hands on from basic
some suggestions. Yeah, I have exactly
that educational content. It's on my X
um x.com/juarez.
It's also linked from puffer.ai.
Just click my articles tab. There's a
guide for programming in ML if you're
new. And then there's a a comprehensive
RL guide on there as well.
It gives you projects to do, papers to
read, things to try.
It's all pretty accessible.
than most RLP PhD grads. I would hope so
because I'm an RL PhD grad and I've been
doing it longer for most RLP PhD grads.
Why is it failing to latch level three?
Like seriously.
Um, clean RL is fine for like learning
stuff, but yeah, when you want your
training to actually work.
We after the terminal change we stopped
admitting any solve segments.
Um, I mean, Anish, that's a tough one.
Like,
Um, he's not going to be able to do
that. He It's a like a complicated ass
paper.
Dude, I couldn't understand half of that
paper if I spent all day on it.
It's a pure theory paper. It's just
pages and pages and pages and pages of
math.
And they sent me the paper that somebody
told him to read and it's just like
nuts.
Yeah. Initi I wouldn't sweat it. Like
if it doesn't work like that's just it's
a very bad fit. Like you shouldn't
really be expecting to be doing
theoretical
lab. Like that's just
it's all derivations. Ethan, there are
no experiments.
Yeah. So, it has no [ __ ] idea. Great.
Um,
This is slow.
Let's get past two at least.
But X is pretty good. You literally see
it doing [ __ ] [ __ ] and it's like no
it's not
like this is completely stupid. It's
like, yeah, it can like if you tell it
to not copy [ __ ] five times, it cannot
copy [ __ ] five times. Yay!
you there. That's like there isn't great
boilerplate code. That's the thing.
[ __ ] I'm sick of like having this
conversation. The models are [ __ ]
dumb.
They're useful, but they're very dumb.
Write
your code and identify code to No,
that's that's [ __ ] troll. Oh,
Yeah, like the oh models are so smart.
PhD level thing is just straight
idiocracy.
It's like great. All the CEOs raised a
bunch of money and lied to you a bunch
and you're dumb enough to believe them.
That's it.
for epoch for history is the beat that
yes that's the correct one
anyways after materialization Terminal
Of course, metadata is already captured
at checkpoint time
in the history sources.
All right. Then why can't it write code
that like a lit like why can't it write
code that undergrads write
I don't know, Anish. Let's see some
NPRs.
Okay, this is fast.
What about without this? This fast.
Yeah, we just need to give it a longer
run.
I guess it's cuz you run out of time,
huh?
That would make sense.
The kind of Yeah, like I said, I don't
speak Zoomer.
I think we need to prioritize buy
advantage within the segment. That's my
guess.
How many people are watching the super
boring research stream?
Not bad. 12 plus whoever's on X.
That's at least moderately amusing,
right?
I think it's you have to prioritize the
sampling within segments.
I think that's got to be it.
I'm I'm going to allow it to like
continue this, but I'm pretty sure it's
just that we need to now prioritize the
within segment sampling.
I think that's it. We prioritize within
segment sampling. We get this thing
stable. We crank up the fraction of
curriculum mems to 50 or 75%.
Yep, that's what we want. Perfect.
The best pop on my list. Welcome.
Yeah, I think this is what we need. So,
man, this gets complicated, right?
Because it's you admit segments,
you admit segments by advantage, you
improve segments by reward, but you
admit segments by advantage.
You sample segments uniformly. You
sample states by advantage and you
improve segments by reward.
Well, no wonder this ended up taking me
more than a week. It's actually like
there's quite a bit of stuff to it.
I'll write those per state signed values
there too. Yeah, this is what I was
hoping that it wouldn't forget. Perfect.
It's fun seeing people do these silly
things in puffer.
Okay.
Warnings. We'll have to get rid of
those.
Okay,
this runs.
We will see if it's any better.
I guess we could say that we were
leaking a tiny bit of domain knowledge,
right?
what kind of RL environment? So, this is
not so much about making an RL
environment. This is a test environment
for the new algorithm.
It is 15 levels of SOAN backto back in
increasing difficulty where you only get
reward for solving a complete level.
So, it's very sparse. It gets
increasingly sparse. And as soon as you
fail to solve a level in time, you go
all the way back to the beginning.
It's a very, very tough exploration
task.
And uh there's not too much shared
structure from one level to the next
with this few levels.
So this is for testing the new algorithm
which is based on attempting to solve
credit assignment using setable
simulator state.
That is the key of what is going on
here.
Uh, it is a new algorithm. What the heck
is that?
Is this LM crap?
Oh, this is random crap, man. This is
language model crap.
Yeah, this is stupid language model
crap. Nothing like that.
No, it's not a policy to judge an
algorithm. So, if you're new around
here, um, if you check puffer.ai,
we build the it's not LLMRL, right? We
build the fastest infrastructure and
some of the best algorithm updates for
small model tabular RAS RL. We build
simulators that run at tens of millions
of steps per second. We can train up to
20 million steps per second on a single
GPU. We basically just train tiny
superhuman models on dedicated
simulators in seconds.
And this is currently algorithm research
on what should be the next major
development in this line of work.
It's it's fine. It's like I know
everybody's doing LLM crap these days,
so it's rare to not see uh to see
something different, but it's very cool
because the algorithms we have access to
are dramatically more powerful than what
you can run on LLMs.
And you can actually do this type of
stuff at very very small compute scale
and develop superhuman policies.
It's very very different from that.
Now this was better until we get stuck
at level 10 for some reason.
Presumably, this will at least give us a
useful log file.
actually shouldn't be that bad if it's
picking old segments anymore.
It's actually it was great and then we
just hard failed at 10.
That should give us useful logs.
And then maybe we'll have to revise the
metric again. Who knows?
different parameters to get a better
store. What are you doing now? Um, it's
not different parameters.
Uh, it's algorithmic variations and it's
not so much trying to get a better
score. What we're currently trying to do
is get the score that we got before with
less domain knowledge.
We're trying to do it fully generally.
Okay. So, this is interesting. We
actually right at the very end we latch
And
What I'm trying to do now, right, is we
have diagnostics that record the
advantages
um for segments that should not have
gone into the buffer
as well as for segments that uh should
have gone into the buffer and didn't.
And then we get to recomputee the scores
under a variety of different metrics and
see if we find any that are going to
more accurately capture data. Benefits
of getting the same score without domain
knowledge that the algorithm will
actually be useful and work across the
other stuff in puffer
algorithm is useless if it has to have a
bunch of domain knowledge.
Wait, what? ABS top K almost always
prefers the offender.
That's bizarre. I thought we were doing
positive.
Was already supposed to be that way.
At least that's an explanation.
Oh, whoops.
Well, init There was a thing that was
already supposed to be a certain way and
it's it basically I was like, "All
right, do this thing." It's like,
"Great. I did the thing." And it didn't
do the thing.
So, like, no wonder I was confused why
the thing didn't work.
There's no way we're stuck on three.
Okay.
We're not getting level 9 ss really.
There we go.
We're probably not devoting enough to
random exploration
because you can't write segments.
Like seeing the progress you make each
week. I'm trying, man. It's tough.
All right. Well, we'll get logs from
Yes.
I should be able to get it solved like
this though.
It does 13 instantly.
Okay, that's interesting.
Oh, is it unstable now?
Why would it be unstable?
Oh, it doesn't make any sense to me.
Okay, it recovers.
Good.
13.
14's open.
It's not getting any souls though,
so I'm just zero.
beating Dota.
So, we could definitely already do it
way way better than the original.
There's no point in doing that because
like just with the pure CPU expense of
that. It's just a ridiculously
it's just that would just be a
ridiculously expensive project because
of how slow the game is and it's too big
of a game to port fully.
Next on the agenda.
I mean, this is currently an algorithm
block of dev.
The goal is to introduce setible
simulation state
and to use that to great effect,
which is what I'm working on now.
and then what what do I want to achieve?
Well, I think that the goal is for the
next co in the next couple of updates,
we're going to get RL to a point where
we kind of just can't come up with dumb
simple counter examples where we think
our algorithm should work and they
don't. We're going to sort of just patch
the remaining flaws in our learning
methods.
And um the goal is to get RL to a point
where it is stable and consistent enough
that pretty much anywhere we go and
apply it, we will be confident that any
failures are not the result of our
algorithm or our models.
And uh as a result, we'll be able to
take on substantially harder
applications.
Um, yeah, but Ethan, you're basically
you're abusing one minor quirk with our
that is possibly a thing, but it's
abusing a minor quirk with the structure
of our ends.
We need to look at that maybe.
We'll see.
There there are a few like quirks like
this. I mean, we have bigger ones
though.
How much work?
Uh the amount of LLM stuff I'm doing
right now. I [ __ ] hate this. Like,
this is pretty much just because we have
a lot of prototyping to do. It's in
CUDA. None of the code from this is
going to get kept at all. All the code
that this is writing is absolutely
terrible. Every single thing is going to
get rewritten. Um, this is purely for
attempting to run a bunch of experiments
very quickly and be able to still have
reasonably good throughput on them.
But, uh, yeah, my hope is that this is
this was honestly too much.
I think it should just be me and
positive advantage is the best.
Wait, what? Unnormalized positive mass
towards the frontier.
Unnormalized positive mass flips most
comparisons back towards the frontier.
Aren't the segments are going to shorten
over time, aren't they?
Oh, actually
they don't on this end, right?
maybe handw write stuff because it's
more fun.
Yeah, this is pretty miserable. I mean,
I will be hand optimizing a lot of stuff
after.
Um, this is not really fun at all or
like interesting, but
this is a very quick way to prototype
stuff that needs like quite a bit of
annoying logging code.
Oh, wait. I didn't didn't see you.
Almost missed this thing. Didn't build.
Hey, Arch.
Oh, there we go.
Just gets stuck for some reason, though.
There's 11.
Oh, there it is.
11 wasn't too bad.
It doesn't do anything. Does it?
No.
That's not terrible.
13.
The annoying thing about the internet is
it's very difficult to tell apart a good
bot and a uh or a bad bot and a very
good troll.
Hey Jess. Um
algorithm is still weird.
uh goes to whack. Um
it's very difficult to come up with a
good way to get like to admit data into
the buffer.
Like I said, I can't you genuinely can't
tell good troll from bad bot sometimes.
a larger buffer. Some more CLNS.
I figure we'll just try this real quick.
Okay. So, we have our good um our good
metric right
for now.
We're sampling uniformly across segments
prioritized within segments.
It is better in some sense because at
least now you probably have eights in
the buffer.
So it should be better.
Now you do latch it there.
You really I think that you should just
not get like really stuck with this one.
It should be more consistent maybe.
It's still stuck. This is very odd.
Maybe this will be good logs. Who knows?
And definitely needs to work with a
bigger state buffer, right?
right, running out of ideas for the day,
but let's see how this does.
Uh, the algorithm is definitely real,
Jess. It's just it's very tricky. Okay.
Wait, what would the highest advantage
state be?
Oh, wait.
Wait. Can you do max Can you do max TD
like that? Like what? TD of one.
Well, that's definitely the sampling
problem.
What does it do? It's the average value
error
cuz it's
you're basically just taking like some
sort of average over um the error of the
value function.
What the issue? Shouldn't high advantage
be right before?
Uh, no. Because
so on average, yes.
But if you take a fixed segment,
right? So the value function is just
going to predict zero everywhere.
And then you're going to end up
assigning one, right?
So your value function is trying to
predict discounted reward. In the
simplest case,
you have a very high gamma value.
So that should push you very far
backwards from the actual reward for the
maximum value.
It's also possible it's getting too late
in the day and I have to think about it,
but I'm pretty sure. Let me try TD real
quick.
weird manner.
Uh no because by definition the value
function is it's trying to it's like
value function minus advantage or
whatever. So by definition that is the
target.
Yeah. You're not predicting exactly like
just discounted rift turn, but
Like what's the advantage two steps
back, All right.
is it?
No, I don't think it is right before the
reward.
I mean, it seems like max advantage is a
very bad metric to sample.
I I think it's trivially the case if you
just set was it lambda one or something
if you're predicting discounted reward,
right? or discounted return.
Discounted return doesn't peak one step
before the reward.
It peaks sometime before because there's
an exponential decay, but there's also a
sum
DD goes down versus Yeah. So if gamma is
very high,
right?
because it's like
discounting goes backwards.
I was doing disc I was doing discounting
backwards. Lovely.
uh some of merced arch
I'm trying to implement this is I'm
trying to use setable simulator state
um to solve massively difficult
exploration problems
Yeah, but for the thing I was thinking
of it's it it does peak right before the
reward. That's correct.
though, you know, maybe that is the
issue.
Yeah, hang on. That is using five pole
horizon weirdly.
Okay, there are a lot of conflicting
pieces here and the more I think about
10,000
4090s
distributed not in the same place.
So that's kind of fine for us.
Um
I don't think we have like any existing
projects.
I guess the main thing would be if
anybody were interested in like helping
us do really large scale ablations on
ton of basic science things. Um, you
know, across all the environments, we
could pretty easily
we should be able to pretty easily
aggregate sweeps across a ton of them.
We'd have to synchronize just the sweep
recommendations,
which would be cheap.
It wouldn't be completely trivial, but
we could do it.
Thousands are currently just mining
stupid crypto. H,
that would be cool.
Maybe we get access to a whole bunch of
GPUs. I mean, we would have to we
definitely have to rerigg some stuff
with our sweeps for all the different
hardware configs.
Presumably we could do some Enough.
puffer.
It'll take a little bit of work, but
could be done.
It's more than just sweeps. It's like,
you know, add feature and then like
sweep that feature. See if better. Lots
of basic science.
I don't even know why I opened that
side.
Got short arms, but it's got pretty big
Faith.
Yeah, this is the I think this is the
main thing is we're losing most of our
data.
This would get us what like three
3x more data.
more data
per segment
cuz basically I had like a quarter of
the end set to curriculum
but in practice it was a much smaller
fraction
um if you count by actual trajectory
There is.
Come on. Did they make it way slower?
No. Okay, it's okay for now.
and it's just stuck on 10.
That's so stupid.
I've not messed with them.
Um,
you know, I think that we're still fine
here. There's still stuff we can do with
This
It's a little tricky the way that this
thing works with segments, isn't it?
Yeah, there's so much crap that we can
still mess with.
Oops, I missed a message.
I have to order
order food on the side here.
This should definitely make it better.
So if it doesn't, there's something
wrong.
And or we have to go back from max
to
or max of state
to random one.
Yeah. Okay. We can do this. We can get
this done.
All right, I have an idea for this. I
think we can like we can substantially
increase the density of our data. That's
probably the main issue.
I mean, it's like
if if you think it makes sense, then try
it and see what happens.
But like
they're not going to perceive sound in
the same way anyways, right? So like
yeah, you can make sound and knobs. It's
just a different type of sensor. There.
did not build. Hang on there.
Make sure it's built.
we'll try we'll try uniform again.
I think with this uniform with this new
density might be good
if this doesn't work.
We'll let this run. We'll do one more
thing and I'm calling it a day.
Okay, hang on. We'll see. We should at
least let this finish
again. Like, it really needs to get 14
or 15
And where did the stupid window go?
All right. As expected, this thing is
crap.
We Yep. This thing is giga crap. We can
just kill this.
And I'm running one more experiment and
I'm calling it a day.
Yes, Arch. There was one thing I didn't
account for,
which I guarantee you doesn't make the
problem harder. I just need to figure
out how to like reaccount for it. So
what I'm doing now
Jeez.
What a load of crap.
Well, we know for sure this is supposed
to work.
If this doesn't work,
This is no longer dependent on advantage
for sampling. It's only dependent on
advantage for admission.
It has the
best tested admission metric that we
could possibly get.
If advantage is bad in any way, it
doesn't suffer from it for sampling at
least
Let's see how this run goes.
This is the last one for today.
So this is
um I believe this is
sum of L1 no sum of positive advantage
for the admission metric.
Uh the sampling is 50% random 50% start
from the beginning.
segments get resampled on terminal.
Um,
I think that's it. Those are the main
things.
And this does reduce it back down to
just um purely the buffer data. I
believe
this is better in some sense. So it
looks like we're getting stuck on
[ __ ] 10.
Yeah, we still have buffer segment
admission problems.
It's basically the difficult thing is
figuring out how we can actually retain
the correct data in the buffer like
admit and retain the correct B data is
very difficult to do.
I'm going to have to go think about
stuff. But I'm tired. It's been a long
dev day. Um, I started early. I'm
calling it. Thank you for tuning in,
folks.
You want to help me out for free?
Starpuffer on GitHub. Be back tomorrow.
Try to solve this tomorrow. Discord if
you want to get involved.